Hey,
we're here with Megan
Miller and Ryan Parson.
We just got done doing a podcast.
Yes we did.
That's fine.
It was that the first one you've done?
I Dunno.
Yeah,
every time it was more fun.
I feel like I yell too much
like Julie Diaz,
you gotta Yo let it out
and then come back to us.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
Don't get me wrong.
I feel bad about it too and I'm like,
I don't even realize I'm at your
house screaming and yelling.
I like Joey the mayhem
experience and accept it.
No worries
ma'am.
Ma'Am.
I'm known mayhem since he was a skinny
youngster when he was hanging around with
margin laymen.
That was back in the day
like coach on the ultimate fighter.
I coached just like mark laymen.
Like I was saying the same
words that he used to say,
but he's way more monotone and like,
ah,
I'm not bought a town.
What are you talking about?
Like like that.
I have a different style
but like realize damn,
I could have went with them so
long that I coach just like a bell.
Yeah.
He said Jujitsu wizard.
That guy is,
he's an encyclopedia of
Jiu Jitsu information,
man.
It's just be get blazed a bunch of tapes.
It's interesting,
man.
He's got everything categorized and
shit and I've talked to him about it.
She just do philosophy
pretty organized about it,
you know?
Yeah.
He's,
he's,
he was the only the organized dude.
It was shocked me.
He would have all those
tapes all lined up.
Like,
man,
I could never do that.
Like,
you know,
this tape sign up and nowhere
in his tape library stuff was,
he was also a duty.
He didn't want to cut weight.
He was like lazy and Shit.
So he would like battle.
Dude.
It's way bigger than him.
Yeah.
It had to be real technical,
but he's just a smart dude.
He's always been a smart dude.
That's a weird world.
Isn't that the world of the coach
that's never been a fighter,
you know,
it's my world.
It was so weird.
He was so stressed to compete too.
I remember he was so stressed out.
I was like shocked.
He was like
kind of,
he would be so amped to,
to coach.
It was a for me.
He'd perform good and you had a good,
they're a good career.
Uh,
grappling ghetto.
Yeah.
Mark Lane.
It's a beast,
but it is a,
it's a weird world,
right?
Isn't it?
Being a coach,
Brian on the sabbath,
talk about it bro,
because,
well,
it's not so much because there's
enough talented fighters are on.
The guys can get that aspect of stop,
stop,
stop.
May Ham was waking up,
the neighbors and the cops came,
so we had to double back.
Now we're in a different location,
far away from the fuzz.
You know,
Shit gets hairy when you're
hanging out with mayhem.
She gets hairy when you're
hanging out with a star,
a bully beat down.
The current hosted the ultimate fighter.
I'm not a host bro coach,
I guess you could say.
Well,
yeah,
I shouldn't say the host
call cohosting don't they
read one of his coaches?
Most of the ultimate fighter,
but I guess,
yeah,
coaching.
I'm not going,
hey,
welcome to this week's about,
I kind of am though.
Got To admit I kind of gotten crazy.
Did you bring in hot fail?
Could narrow.
Yeah.
We probably have her buddy fight.
Shoot a buck style.
They have books.
They man,
you know,
it's very nice to you.
It's a very nice,
you guys got to kill a camp now
on his him and may can sister gym.
So kings off.
How's the mark?
Munoz is jam.
So Vangelis Shogun do their camps.
May Have uh,
Chris Sauce is in skied.
Mark Munoz.
Jake Ellenberger is added.
Dude,
what'd you think about Ellenberger
made perfect sense to me.
I felt like,
you know,
like we train the hell out of that kid
and he went in there and did his job.
Yeah.
He fucking knew what was going to happen.
He knew what shields
is going to try to do.
So yeah.
So he did opposite indeed.
Well thank you guys for
coming on the podcast.
It's a pleasure as always.
Thank you Ryan for participating.
It was,
we're really worried you were
going to try and hit this out.
It was much more fun,
right?
You won.
You were awesome,
man.
We would've never had that fucking
crocodile story if it wasn't
irrational.
Fear of animals could now
he's never gone to Florida.
Thank you Mr. Miller.
Thank you Mary Joe Rogan and we're,
we're out.
You know today maybe it'll help
if you pick up bags of sand.
Eddie Bravo on the podcast,
we dropped some knowledge,
drop some knowledge about weed.
He had a cure up.
Some haters.
We've talked about this,
unfortunately ed,
he's got some haters online and people
make some unfortunate statements and one
of those statements was made about him
wanting to being a bad role model because
he says that marijuana enhanced his
life and marijuana help does Jujitsu and
marijuana helps us music
and his creativity and some
would Jujitsu guy who we
both respect an amazing Jujitsu guy,
but unfortunately he's just,
he's got a shitty idea about what weed is.
So we,
I used to be just like you complete.
Oh,
I used to hate potheads.
Then how was the,
I was worse than you until I did some
research and found out the truth.
You could find out the truth
to come $3 just buy in,
buy some books.
You can go to Barnes and nobles and they
have a whole section on weed and it's
not negative stuff.
It's a whole section on the week.
But it's funny because when someone makes
a big statement like that and it makes
a big deal at uh,
uh,
you,
you smoking weed and
says you're an idiot man,
they,
they do way more harm for the cause
of anti week than they do good.
You know,
because he calling you an idiot.
All it does is make them look silly
and irrational and then it gives you an
opportunity to defend yourself.
And then when you defend yourself,
fucking facts start flying out and
information and emotional testimony where
you're talking about in your praising the,
the positive effect.
It's way more advertisement for weed.
Every time someone steps up and
say something shitty about weed,
the backlash is way bigger now
than it's ever been before.
The move movement actually needs people
like called Credo to call us idiots.
Cause then we bring
out the facts and then,
you know,
we,
the people are on the fence about weed.
You know,
a good portion of them when
presented with a correct fats,
they'll go,
oh shit,
they'll jump over people way
on the other side of the fence.
We're never going to get those guys.
Not right now.
They're too caught in their ways.
That's fine.
I mean,
I used to be there.
I totally understand what their feelings
are about drugs fucking up your life
and ruining and becoming a crutch.
I know exactly what you're saying.
You're,
you're absolutely right there.
For some people,
some drugs can become a crutch.
What,
what marijuana is to me and
what it is to Eddie is not,
it's a spiritual thing.
It's,
it's,
it's an an theologian.
It's,
it's something that connects you to truth.
It's something that connects you to a
higher feeling of understanding a higher
sensitivity.
And,
uh,
I,
I refuse to accept the fact
that that's bad for you.
I think if used and harnessed correctly,
it's most certainly good for you.
And that if people learned
about how good it is for you,
it can enhance their life,
including cops,
man,
including all these people that think
it's bad and they think people should go
to jail for it.
It can enhance your life too,
man.
There's,
there's a lot of shit that
people should go to jail for it.
You're right.
There's a lot of drugs
that are terrible for you.
You're fucking right.
There's a lot of drugs
and if you sell them,
you're a piece of shit and you
should be removed from society.
I agree with you.
But pots I,
one of a man needs thrown in there for
the all the wrong reasons and if you look
at it correctly,
you realize that this is something that
makes people happy and it's nature and
it's put here on earth.
People have had a symbiotic relationship
with this plan for 10,000 fucking years
and the only reason we keep talking
about it is because we will get thrown in
jail for it.
Even though the state says it's legal,
the feds,
the DEA,
they,
they think they could just come in and
just ignore state law and just put people
in jail.
That's why I'm talking
about it all the time.
I'm trying to do my part
in the legalization process
to open people's eyes once
it's totally,
completely legal and everyone's cool with
them and I'm not going to really talk
about it no more.
There's really no need.
Everyone's going to know.
It'll be,
it'll be knowledge.
It be something that's coming.
Understood instead of right now
it's commonly misunderstood.
That's the end of our
marijuana pro program.
Dr 10th Planet J J.
Dot Com bitches represent
you hadn't done the documentary,
but isn't that funny that that works
that way that someone sees a shirt,
it's a dope shirt and like this
documentary was gonna fucking rule.
Yes.
Cause they see the shirt.
But it's you,
it's you.
It's,
I mean like don't,
don't want to undersell it.
You're the first one,
but you're being a regular human being.
When you said as you go,
you gotta get me one asap.
Like,
I want to wear it on fear factor.
I want to wear it on the podcast.
So we rush it.
We get it.
A couple of sets of you,
a couple sentences like other people
that we know that are important to us and
you wear it and it fucking blows up.
Like literally blows up.
Well that's nice that I can do that.
Pretty easy.
So what was going on?
So when you take it,
when you partake,
partake.
Yes,
it's a,
it's apples.
Cabbage.
It's a,
it's a bad,
massively different podcasts.
Yeah,
it's different,
right?
Like it's cause it's,
you know,
well it's also the one,
the only
podcasts or one,
the only ones that I know of where they
let you know if they're smoking weed.
Kevin Smith does too.
He smokes weed through his whole posse.
Really?
Dude,
he's the biggest honor I've ever met.
He's constantly what can believe.
That's all he does now.
He smokes weed all day.
He's obsessed.
It's fascinating.
We haven't gone,
first time I came in here though,
you guys were doing the volcano
and I did not partake at all,
but I still got high.
We got so lazy with that.
Volcanoes.
Volcanoes do its work and it's
just way too easy to roll a joint.
I liked the volcano though.
It's healthier for your body.
I really should go back to.
Yeah,
but I was sitting next to it.
I was sitting next to it.
It does go through way too fast,
but that's not really a
problem here in California.
At least we hope it's not.
It's in 45 days.
They're supposed to close
all the dispensary's.
My Guy says it's horse shit.
He says he's not going anywhere.
He says they only gave those things
to 16 different people and he said,
uh,
you get to Michigan.
What do you mean they did?
The machine just cleared out Michigan,
all of the medical marijuana,
Michigan and closed down
all the fucking that stores,
all of them.
That's what I've been.
People on Twitter have
been telling us years.
Really?
That's crazy.
Now I'm all there,
have a,
they have a very fresh program.
It's very young.
California is just so deeply,
deeply ingrained.
I doubt that that can happen here.
Like trying to close all the McDonald's,
you know,
would take,
we would find some place we would find
the place because all the Mcdonald's you,
but there's one on that corner too.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's really gross,
man.
It's really,
it's one of the grossest
things about our government,
the fact that they're continually
going after marijuana and it's,
there's no evidence whatsoever that
does anything bad and yet to let and
cigarettes as slide rather than the table.
The fucking,
the weeds of death.
These cigarettes are killing
400,000 plus people every year.
And nobody says a word.
They're just sliding on through.
You know,
everyone's sending jackbooted thugs to
go raid medical marijuana dispensaries
and take all their profits and take all
their pot and make them go to court for
it and never give it back to them and
take millions of dollars from them.
It's amazing.
It's amazing that these are,
these are basically thugs
for pharmaceutical companies.
So speaking of getting
high and look at it,
ridiculous shit.
This is a documentary called Kubrick's
odyssey by this guy named Jay Wiener,
who believes that Stanley
Kubrick fake the moon landings.
Granted he also believes is
an alien base on the moon.
Then he believes that that's the reason
why they faked the moon landing since,
cause they didn't want to go to the
monk cause there's aliens there.
What's the lesson?
Is your beliefs to yourself
until you come to the good one?
Awesome.
Well,
what's
is the theory is interesting,
but what's,
what's fascinating about it is
he points to the symbolism in,
um,
uh,
the,
jacket,
the shining,
the symbolism and Stanley Kubrick's
version of the shining and how that
symbolism directly relates with along
with numbers and all sorts of things that
he changed that directly relate to Apollo,
to the Apollo Moon landings,
including the room,
the crazy room where everything happened
is the exact amount of distance between
the earth and the moon.
You know,
and then he changed it from what it is
in the book and made it the distance to
the moon,
you know,
so,
and then there's all this symbolism
like the boy is wearing that.
And Apollo a rocket sweater
in this one particular scene,
like I'm not doing it any justice.
It's very,
very detailed and it also detailed about
the way that he believes they faked the
videos of people on the moon but I
think called front screen projection,
which was a technique that Kubrick used
in 2001 and in this technique is not
perfect,
but it's basically the
beginning of green screens.
What they did before they
invented green screen and this,
this technique has a telltale like sort
of a line between the boundaries of the
real front,
uh,
the real screen or the real stage rather.
And then the screen behind it,
which is an image which
tries to make it electric,
it's a vast distance when
in reality it's just a wall.
And this telltale line,
he shows it all is a pallet photos.
I mean it's really kind of crazy if you,
if you look at it,
you look at the videos,
look at the photos and you know the stills
of the astronauts bouncing around the
moon,
you're like,
that looks exactly like that.
This is,
this is it.
To couple that with the fact that the
same background exists in different Apollo
moon landing missions and their background
where they're supposed to be miles
away from each other.
They're supposed to be in a
completely different place,
but you have to have the same background
as the price of discrepancies about
when it comes to the imagery
and what he believes.
He believes that people
actually went to the boom,
but when they got there,
the problem was there was aliens there
and he points to the clementine lunar
orbiter,
which took photographs of uh,
uh,
a crater and this crater had a
very distinct like blue dome in it,
you know,
take it on the grant of salt.
But it's interesting just to watch
people go deep into the rabbit hole.
You know what I mean?
This guy must suspend a giant chunk of
his life trying to prove that Stanley
Kubrick fake the moon landings.
It's pretty interesting,
man.
Might be a hundred percent horseshit.
Interesting.
Here's the whole thing.
I was thinking the whole time he told
me that extended qubit fake to the moon
landings don't you think can be pitching
so much other fake shit like guys,
let's also fake this and like
why would he go to make movies?
Um,
I think what the idea is is that the
government accordingly with his hypothesis
is that the government wanted
to fake the moon landings.
And what they did was
they came to Kubrick,
they explained to him why they want to
fake the moon landings and they gave him
access to all sorts of
scientific information.
And cubic is a mathematical genius and
he was obsessed with space flight and it
was really like really,
really into that shit.
And so what they did was they gave him
access to all of NASA's different studies
and NASA is different,
you know,
technology and allowed him to have like
basically an unlimited budget to produce
this and to produce 2001 a space odyssey.
So you could do them sort
of in conjunction with each
other and the technology
that he could use and portraying 2001
he can use it basically the same stuff
and,
and faking the movement headaches and
they would help him get him rich and give
them access to information.
And his,
this guy's take on it is the
access to information was uh,
the elites of society.
The,
the hidden,
you know,
culture that runs the hidden societies
that run our government for real.
And you know,
the,
the privileged few like an eyes wide
shut and we know that like was talking to
the skull and bones as long
as weird fucking groups.
Somebody Shit heads get
into at the Bohemian Grove.
You ever seen that stuff?
We're all these elites from all
over the world and me and his son,
they fucking sacrifice in effigy and
they worship this mold left the owl God.
Alex Jones has a whole video where he
snuck into Bohemian Grove and filmed all
this shit.
It's pretty interesting.
What's all,
what else is interesting is that when
he made the movie eyes wide shut,
that was his last movie.
That movie was sort of about a lot
of it was about like hidden society.
It's like secret societies shut up.
Yeah.
So he's kind of,
he was a brilliant,
brilliant,
brilliant guy and he was also
a brilliant chess player.
And what they think is that he did
it was like he hit a lot of things,
symbolism and,
and you know,
in different imagery in,
in the movie to sort of tell a story.
And this guy breaks it down.
Of course.
It's just,
it's hypothesis.
It could be a hundred percent horse shift.
Yeah.
But it's interesting.
So see it or not,
I don't give a fuck.
Ah,
Bert Bert,
bert.com leads gentlemen
B e r t three times
oculus.
Yeah.
I follow him on Twitter.
Thanks.
Well thank you.
Always good time.
We hugged it out.
Powerful Ra should fear
done with doing the podcast.
Good Times as usual.
It was one probably like the 10th time.
No more than that.
You've done it.
How many times you don't know.
I've just done it.
We've done it a hundred
and how many of them Brian?
Hiring 40 or 740 something like that,
but there's a few early on to,
or we were just doing on the couch.
Right.
We all like lean back and pretend
we're comfortable with and couch sucks.
It's totally cool.
It's just like so much smarter use
office chairs when you think about it.
Who sits up straight all day for office?
People going to use office chairs and
that'll catch your head is in my room now.
Which saying?
Yeah,
we recycle here.
Death Squad.
It was,
it was blocking my other cousins and such
a board or just blocked my like hell,
it's for like a year.
Really?
I just put it in front of the other couch.
And then what'd you do eventually?
He got rid of the old couch.
No,
I moved them to this
space for a while now.
Oh,
that's all you had to do?
I haven't been to your place.
Which court?
Okay.
What was I going to to hell?
Relationship.
My leg.
Why not?
What is it?
Arm.
I got you.
I got to vaporizers.
I gotta.
I gotta get that.
Nice.
Give one a charity.
I think I got to donate to the
little bit of comedy store.
That's a good move.
As we look at those attachments,
people break those dose and
no one will ever donate it.
Then once fucks it,
we'll just give it to it.
They might,
they might.
They might say like,
Oh,
well we're done here.
Let's get another with your San Diego
sounded real profit right now they're
closing down all the pawn
shops from San Diego.
It scares me.
Well,
San Diego,
Super Republican.
Donald Rumsfeld lives down there.
Apparently this a corona.
There's this,
the city of Corona.
It's like a corona islands,
like the little peninsula.
It's like one of the most wealthy
towns in America and Donald,
the middle one of those there.
They don't want to know
pot anywhere near San.
It's a lot of Republicans,
San Diego,
a lot of military to really?
Yeah.
Everybody loves Pato.
Even down there.
Especially now when I they do,
of course you do this,
this conservative people down there,
they just don't want it and you know
there's a lot of those fucking guys with
their mustache,
my fucking neighborhood.
You know,
they was just progress.
I've get that.
I get when there's a dispensary,
if near a neighborhood and you buy
something you want to like go around the
corner and smoke.
I'm like I don't want to
smoke or for something.
Somebodies yard.
It's true.
This is the problem.
Yeah.
That is the problem.
The problem is when it's too near
residential or can your school,
some people want to argue with that.
I was real close to the drug store to
school but also not really that close and
people aren't doing stuff there.
Yeah,
exactly.
And very few people are in a drug
store anywhere on Ventura Boulevard.
I shouldn't say that cause they might,
it's probably a lot of people that get
their prescriptions and just fucking Jack
right in the parking lot and know
failing an oxycontin thing probably.
Actually that's really normal.
Yeah.
They pop those bitches.
Could anywhere material
and he's busy street.
It's like,
yeah,
that's fine.
That's totally fine.
Malls should have punch ups.
They should.
Yeah,
those fucks.
Someone's going to make a fortune
putting a pot shop in the mall.
Do,
are you going to make a
fortunate that someday?
Do you worry about this backlash?
All the shit that's going on right now,
they're trying to close pot stores.
A lot of times it gets,
it gets to be really inflammatory that
people send a good closing shops left and
right.
And I'm like,
hold on.
The only news I really heard is they're
sending out 16 letters and they're
shutting down.
They're giving those 16 stores
45 days and make no arrests,
45 days shut down.
And only 16 out of the thousands that are,
you know that story when they
came to me there was no one left.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But like I don't know exactly why and
what they mean when they say not operating
in the state laws.
Yeah.
Well you're,
you have a real good point about people.
I'm reactionary.
There's one where like the end
is near or at worst that too,
but also a what you were talking about
how they're supposed to be nonprofit.
That's,
none of them are nonprofit
out there making crazy cash.
They have employees that you'd like that.
I get that,
but it would change the
real change if you know,
Paul was fucking afraid.
Oh,
it'd be the real change.
Or if you only paid enough to my rowing
fruit.
Yeah,
if I was free,
that would be the real change.
It's everybody just had pot and you
just gave people things for pot was like
some sort of a weird barter system or
you got paid to grow pot just enough so
that you,
you know,
would you be able to get it around?
It's really good to the supermarket.
Why not?
Why not just come by?
But the idea that you could get paid
just enough to justify you growing it,
but you couldn't get Bentley money.
Like you know,
that's what you have to get somebody
going to run the whole dispensary pay the
more they don't just get
just enough to get by.
Well that's part of this whole thing
that's like a hundred grand a year.
That's a business.
That's the person that's running it.
Right.
What about the profit for
the actual business itself?
How much whatever you want to
make with a regular business.
I don't know how much it's a nightmare.
President of Nike made a shit load.
Yeah,
he should.
She started Nike.
Go ahead.
And you make a slippery slope,
right?
Once you give up anything when
it's really not for profit,
what's for what purpose anyway,
but the way it's written,
it is I think any medical drug,
it's for profit.
Right?
So like what is this nonprofit?
I guess the idea is to protect the
people problem the first place.
Yeah,
but they are there.
Yeah.
But tomatoes aren't like profitable the
way marijuana is probably the wrong and
it's not patentable.
And since it's a psychoactive substance,
I think they feel like anything
psychoactive they have to control.
You know,
I feel like,
you know,
if they have some things that are
psychoactive that they control,
if other ones they don't control it,
I think maybe get a little
testy about that shit.
And then I think pharmaceutical
companies would get testy about it.
I think they put a lot of pressure on
politicians and that's where all the shit
comes from.
It's a direct,
it's not a result of the people.
There's a White House website.
We can uh,
asking,
you know,
what was your question
is the most important?
Quit number one by far is
why isn't it marijuana legal?
That's number one.
It's like,
quit oppressing me.
You know,
this bothers,
nobody bothers nobody around me.
So like stop,
leave me alone.
I'm not doing anything to anyone.
Yeah,
me knees,
government meanies cut that shit out.
Yo were hip to you.
We know it's done it.
We're all just people stupid.
Get it together because it's
something in ice water and stay black.
Duncan Trussell to
fisting with flashlights,
Uno jokes.
One of them is going to stuff up as,
but now,
now that's not the proper
use of these things.
These are sex tools,
not sex toys.
Yeah,
we've,
we've got rid that today.
It's probably a bit in that sex tools,
not toys,
toys and a purpose.
They just don't do any open up for me.
I'll kill my fleshlight material.
I won't.
All right.
Which one is 10 minutes on the
flush letting you do that shit.
What's this one model act?
Exact same video as we did
last time you were here.
I gave him a flashlight to what happens?
Women throw them out.
That's what happens.
Yeah.
Flashlights laying around your house.
Chicks fine and they go with Fuck Dunkin.
They need to make it.
They need to make it safe.
Special fleshlight safe with the
code and it looks like a golf club.
You know,
it's like something
that wouldn't throw out.
You need to put a Paki
in its pocket and it's,
he puts Siri in it and then not have
it be like a voice to your flesh.
So you talk to your flashlight.
Tell me I'm good.
Oh baby,
I'm sucking your cock.
I bet they will have that.
They'll have like to,
they don't leave an iPhone
sleeve for your flashlight.
I can't believe they
just put headphones on.
You know,
and you can actually
even watch a video too.
You could have it hooked
up to an Ipad as well.
So you're watching a
porno video on the IPAD.
Do you know they have a Chinese,
um,
Dick Sucking robot.
They came in with a robot.
They call it like a
seaman extraction device,
but it's essentially like this tall and
feel like a tube and it sucks in your
consciousness.
That's probably horrendously rude.
Ten five feels terrible.
But they have it.
Course.
I'm surprised they don't.
I'm surprised it blow job robotics
hasn't isn't like a huge industry.
Well,
the Siri thing is going
to change all that.
And the only thing,
I think so everyone wants to fuck Syria
like so many of my friends want to fuck.
That's what Brian wants.
Syrian.
It's his voice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Steve Jobs,
I think,
I think the logical thing
is to change the voice.
The Steve Jobs,
since he died like one week before
Siri was announced or released.
Yeah.
Why does it have to be a robot voice?
Can you adjust the voice that he
died the day after it was announced?
Yeah.
The day after he missed.
That was the first speech that he never
gave the keynote speech or whatever it
was,
whatever big announcement speech Kim
Cook Tim Cook did and then he died.
They have different voices
in different countries,
so they have a like an Australian
voice and a British voters.
Those.
Yeah,
but I guess they don't work as good
like because he doesn't understand your
accent and words like languages,
like Australians,
like say pubs or whatever they say.
Right,
right,
right.
They have a bunch of
different shit going on.
Oh,
you're obsessed with that,
huh?
You're obsessed with Siri.
It's fun to play with.
I want to get it.
Hmm.
I want one too,
but you have a droid fucking me,
man.
I'm losing my words now.
What happened?
I love the Troy.
What happens,
how you're telling me it's the most
amazing fun of all time and I went around
and I fucking razzed iPhone owners
and I'm like the droids batter,
but it sucks,
man.
It's like they did a software update,
so now it's gone back to like an
ancient voicemail from months ago.
I just decided to do that random times.
Pandora will turn on at random fucking
times and also it reconfigured my address
book so I have problems
finding phone numbers.
It was a software up.
They fucked,
fucked everything.
Fuck that software update.
Once a blackberry killed all my numbers.
I lost every number in my fucking phone.
There were all garbled jumble
and half of them were missing.
You know,
they're just gone.
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
I had to let go back to my
computer and start from scratch.
I had a backup.
Yeah,
they're done dude.
They have nothing there.
They have these little stupid
devices with buttons on them.
Right.
When the new iPhone comes out,
they are surface drops out or what?
A disaster.
His ass or,
yeah.
And then it's not just the iPhone anymore.
They're good.
That droid bionic now.
Ooh,
I saw what somebody had one
of those other shows weekend.
That's a fucking amazing phone.
What does he do in the camera?
Holy Shit Dude.
The camera has so many different options
tomorrow.
New iPhone beat them all works better,
right?
No.
Everything text on its
face detection as cropping.
It's got,
it doesn't have that
4.5 inch screen though,
son.
Yeah,
that big ass.
You know why they did a report of why,
you know the iPhone
isn't gone to that yet,
is that the screen is a certain size
of screen that once it gets too big,
you can't do it one handed anymore.
You have to hold with two hands and that's
the size of the iPhone to actually be
the biggest it usually can
get for the average person.
So that makes sense.
That totally makes sense.
I think it's also a battery life
issue,
man.
Those,
those droids battery lives
are always out of juice.
My droids.
Totally.
I got an iPhone now.
Yeah.
I want to get her horizon
and style comedy money.
You've been fucking headline
and comedy clubs down,
man.
You're actually working.
Yeah,
it's an awesome dude.
You're out there headlining on the road,
right?
It's you just also launched yourself
into a professional comics 10 scally APA.
Thank you.
I love you.
Start off needed one so badly mad.
You needed one.
An agent that you weren't talented.
What kind of car you gotta get?
You gotta get a car?
Yeah,
start with the car for it.
I've seriously thought of that.
I think that,
uh,
I think that when I finally
do get that fucking car,
we're going to have a long conversation.
I'll get you that helped me
pick one out or something.
I don't know what kind
of car when I can't,
I'm not a car guy.
So it's like,
well,
um,
was a mini Cooper too expensive?
Is that was the deal with that?
Like the one that you have
for while the lease expired?
Those are good cars though.
Why not just get one of those?
Because they're a,
I've thought about it.
Like I used to love mini coopers
and this sounds so weird and maybe,
I'm sorry to say it,
but like I think like a really
nice comfortable fucking
like car driving through
traffic freaks me out.
Driving through traffic in La makes
me think it's the end of the world.
I feel like having nervous breakdowns,
you look at it all these fucking shitty
vans and then you feel like you're right
at the first episode of the walking dead.
Like everything's about to fall apart.
So I want some kind of
giant comfort bubble.
Like Ford Edge.
Yeah.
If I've got to go,
go rolling through hell,
was that what you have?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Something that's just like makes you
forget for a second year or something.
Nice.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
Years in five years now,
I don't know.
How am I going to take two?
I'm not going to get into
debt for a car as a thing.
I never want to do at least two or
$300 a don't want to lease smart.
They're smart.
You know,
brought the money to buy a car right now.
You should at least get your car fixed
once you get it fixed so you can drive
it.
They can do that.
You can try everyone really rough.
Does it?
Totally stop it.
They fix cars.
You don't have to throw them
away when they break down.
They're all green with Kasi stairs.
Oh,
maybe I'll get it fixed.
Duncan Trussell does not have a car.
Like he doesn't have a car.
I have a car.
I have a fall though.
89 what's important is
Duncan trussell's now baller,
he's officially professional comedian all
because of this cause this podcast and
his the lavender out cause the internet.
The Internet has embraced.
Thank you.
God bless here and giving him occupation.
They shit.
What is this?
This looks like flashlights.
They must be yours.
Sweet.
Let me just smuggled out with my office.
Right.
Cuddle.
Cuddle them so I can have lucid dream.
I got the last thing.
Is it really more up to them now?
Do you think that your woman's
going to have any issue with those?
Cause we have had friends that we give
them to them and then Duncan Trussell
their girlfriend throws them away.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I don't think mine is that kind of girl.
I think she's going to go.
Can you use the butt end
of this flashlight for me?
Stick it up your ass.
Well I have to so we got to fill fast bro.
That's like a fist of iron.
That's about it.
I get it.
I get one in a quarter.
Yeah.
So God damn son,
why do you think I'm with anyway?
Because you like big butts
and put it in the man hours,
man.
I,
that's all me.
That's all my stretch.
So that's the problem.
And have a stretch problems right
out when she has an accident.
Launching out.
How's the new things
that's supposed to be good?
The new thing,
the thing,
the movie,
it looks all right looking
for a movie tonight.
I just have you seen drive?
Yes.
You like it?
I liked it.
So she has a little bit of a
problem with extreme violence.
That's a tough one to
watch and mixed company.
Now if I was with my friends,
probably enjoyed it more.
What did I see last night?
I saw the um,
the tower heist with Eddie Murphy.
How was that?
It was okay.
I had pretty next to nothing
expectations and I enjoyed the movie.
Like I enjoyed it.
It's Eddie Murphy back to dropping f bombs
and being Eddie Murphy and they still
are not playing Ben Stiller.
He playing a little bit
different of a role,
which is nice and it's a lot of
corporate groups about the corporate guys
fucking do a little more little suckers.
And then it turns into like a
family friendly comedy at the end.
But other than that,
it's pretty sweet.
Kevin Pereira joins us from the podcast
freshly from one of our best podcasts
I've got to say to do.
We've done two so far and
they're both fucking awesome man.
You got such a wide variety of interests
and viewpoints and you got a little bit
of crazy conspiracy theorist in you,
but realist along with it.
It's not the,
you're not reaching a healthy dose of a
tin foil hat is sometimes a good thing.
Have you ever sat down with Alex Jones?
Have you ever had him on your show?
I,
you know what,
I tweeted out,
I wanted to interview him and I
tweeted out one of his articles and,
and he was such a polarizing character
that the backlash from tweeting that out
made people not want to listen to
the message I was trying to give.
So I'm a little reluctant from that,
but,
but what I have seen from
him at times is this so far,
pretty interesting to me.
What about if I had him
come on or as a podcast?
I think you would be the
perfect counterpoint.
Would you sit in and have us off podcast?
I'd love to.
Alex Jones here.
Okay.
With Kevin Pereira.
Kevin is from g four attack of the show.
Attendees of the show is
a new world order device.
What they're doing is
softening up the idea.
It's attack gets attack of the show.
We're all friends here.
Uh,
I,
we are owned happily buy in
via Comcast,
so general electric,
they're shooting fucking bombs.
He goes Kennison Anya,
he's amazing.
Happily chat with him.
He's awesome.
We got that with him in Texas.
He came to the fights.
We,
uh,
we had Margaritas during the day with
Alex and then we went to the UFC that
night.
I didn't get to hang with them,
but Joey Diaz gave him a pot cookie
and put them on the fucking moon.
Oh.
Allegedly.
He actually said on a show the next day
that he has smoked pot with me once a
year just to try it out and see
if I'm in the decriminalization.
So good.
Good
for him,
man.
It's true.
Once a year I come into town and I get,
we,
we could smoke a little weed.
I love it.
Does it,
does the polarizing nature of his
character concern you in terms of aligning
yourself?
No,
I'm it much who I am.
I don't think anybody has any questions,
you know,
I mean anybody who knows me,
they know me from the podcast.
Right.
You're not going to,
I don't think it's confusing.
I think I find a lot of what
he says fascinating and I
don't buy into all of it,
but I to buy into something of it.
He's got a great video on what
we're talking about tonight,
but provoca tourists or,
yeah,
we was talking about um,
the uh,
the um,
protest,
the WTO protests in Seattle and uh,
how it was set up where these military
people would come in and it caused
violence and they were wearing
like ski masks and Shit.
They were breaking windows,
they were wearing fucking military
issue boots and they want up getting,
they want of going into a safe
house and then they get a,
they,
the cops negotiate with them
and they let them all go.
Yeah,
I mean it's like,
it's so gross.
He documents it in great detail.
There's videos from occupy where,
where people are in the crowd,
they're screaming,
they're trying to rile up the people in
the frontline as they're approaching the
riot cops.
The riot cops step aside after telling
people you can not go down the street.
And a line of eight of them walks
right on through the police line.
Then they close up and not
arrested the dudes that walk on by,
but they look like plain
clothes protestors.
That's already happened.
It's already happened.
The what is the justification?
How do they sleep at night knowing that
they're doing that kind of shit and just
doing that job,
man,
that's like Nazi Germany Shit,
man.
That's like Earl.
Well,
yeah,
and it's,
it's,
it's creepy that you can get an
American citizen to trick other American
citizens like that.
But again,
we talked about desensitization.
They don't see,
they don't see Americans.
I don't see you and I potentially,
they see dog.
They see rabid dogs who are
uneducated and hippies and x,
y and z.
That's what they see and they're
just getting their paycheck.
They're just motherfuckers
see were riled up again.
Oh,
this is the time clutching
flashlights and health of brain,
so clearly I'm in the
right minds or credibility.
Clearly I'm in the riots.
Substantially undermines your credibility.
Anyway.
Follow Kevin on Twitter.
It's p.
Right?
Yeah.
I got to get an easier one than that.
Yeah,
that's hard.
Perera should have it spelled like career,
like Porsche went through days.
Carrera Perrera.
Is it Portuguese?
Yeah.
I can't look it up.
What the guests,
how do you say it in Portuguese you
got say it with a mouthful of bread and
angrily then it's Portuguese.
That's only once you get for tie down.
A mouthful of octopus soup is regularly
different than Brazilian Portuguese.
Is it a different way
of pronouncing things?
I mean,
I think there's,
there's like a region,
regional dialects and whatnot,
but it's still fundamentally
the same language.
It just put a little spin on it.
Brazil is so strange,
man.
What a crazy country.
They speak Portuguese in
their middle South America,
right?
Everyone around them to speaking
Spanish and they speak Portuguese.
Good fighters,
good tankers,
good party.
My friend Kevin Pereira,
folks,
that's it.
Oh,
okay.
What's the meaning of life?
Try and be nice to people.
Avoid eating fat.
Read a good book every now and then.
Get some walking and tried
to live together in peace
and harmony with people of
all creeds and nations.
Oh my God.
I'm walking in and read
a book once in a while.
How?
Say that I won't eat fat.
Did that just give you a chills?
Yes.
[inaudible].